I'm out of the whole music scene do
people like Drake people consider them
probably the best rapper of all time
right now he's also in an era that where
like a bunch of rappers aren't like like
once you hit the top you don't get shot
you know what I mean so he's like okay
he's like so he's better than mace and
he's also
[Music]
ironically even though we're bringing
this up I I feel like it's um I don't
know maybe I we've been talking about it
for so long and I feel like now that
it's happened for some reason it didn't
seem as cool as it was going to be but
there was this fight that Tommy Fury
fought Jake Paul oh yeah I feel like we
should talk about this he finally lost
right he did he did lose he blamed Drake
and I that makes sense I'll tell you
what I didn't watch the fight and I I
was one of those guys that was like um
okay this is his first real boxer he's
gonna fight he's gonna be tested and um
after he lost I actually like him more
because of what he said so what he said
was he's like he he didn't have like
some like
um poor sport excuse or anything like
that he goes you know what he out uh
boxed me that night I took it on the
chin and he goes Don't Judge Me by my
wins judge me about my losses and see
what happens and I'm like I I actually
really liked the way like he he
portrayed himself after because I
thought you know with this like
douchebag image you would think oh [__]
oh [__] Island ref and then this and the
[__] slippery [__] ground and like
all kinds of [__] he just kind of
took it like a man and I'm like like an
actual regular fighter yeah I'm like I'm
excited to see what he come if he comes
back from it but you say he blamed Drake
after
because Drake bet on him and there's a
drake wedding curse that's funny is he
bet on Izzy right or dude Drake is like
oh for five for all the on big bills
yeah yeah if he bets on you you're
losing I bet he didn't bet on the Chiefs
huh he bet on like Jorge massive at all
he bet on like oh just just all these
people that have like Izzy the fact that
glass on the fifth round like that and
his last title fight yeah pretty when he
was winning yeah when he was winning he
was winning yeah I'm out of the whole
music scene do people like Drake I think
so yeah yeah I think a lot of people
like Drake yeah yeah okay people do you
like people consider him people consider
him probably the best rapper of all time
right now what yeah I know isn't that
crazy he passed uh didn't he like win
the top like sales I think in terms of
lyricism
sales like Artistry what he's been in
how long he's been able to dominate
longevity yeah multiple decades he's so
relevant
he's also in an era though where like a
bunch of rappers aren't like like once
you hit the top you don't get shot you
know what I mean so he's like okay he's
like so he's better than mace and he's
also
hey no he's not better than me I like me
you also got to think about like the the
um the distribution era too right like
it's like the fact that he's alive
during a time where we have things like
Spotify so when you're talking about
platinum or record sales the the numbers
are completely different right it's like
how um
what was it I think it was the post
Malone Swae Lee uh Spider-Man song oh
yeah yeah that one went like 15 platinum
or something like that and that's like
sweetly jumping on the track and it's
like now now you you can like out of
nowhere because of some uh like you know
which rightfully so too like well
deserved in a different way but like
just through like anomalies or viral
Sensations you can be like the number
one charter of all time musically just
because the distribution methods are way
crazy but at the same time he's for the
culture like he goes to all the battle
rap [__] things like he's like he's
about like bars and [__] like he's not
just he also collabs with all these
up-and-comer rappers that nobody's ever
heard of and he kind of puts them on you
know so I think a lot of people putting
on all these UK guys that's what I mean
those guys one two plus three yeah yeah
that African that African UK stop is
pretty dope you put them on because
they're just they're just their own
little subculture with no mainstream
shine so you he put them on to the world
in in America and all that yeah yeah oh
damn that one song where he goes how can
I be homophobic my [__] is gay
love it love it and it makes it better
because he has a UK accent for sure you
know what I mean you actually makes it
really cool and guys in rap songs they
can get away with saying crazy [__] that
no one else could ever get away with
have you listed on any actual short
stuff recently oh dude he's talking
about how like uh he's like his homie's
sister is like 15 and he can't resist
and I'm like bro what it's correct I'm
like man somebody's letters are crazy
yeah Too Short's always been nuts though
it's a major pass yeah you can't get rid
of these guys but anyways back to the
Jake Paul fight
did anybody watch it highlights I just
watched the one highlight of him
dropping Tommy yeah did you watch it I
watched a couple Clips uh but you didn't
actually pay-per-view it right no I
couldn't find a good stream either in a
legal stream I couldn't find it
um but I do think from the exchanges
that I saw
Tommy Fury did land the bigger punches
the boar punch combinations I think he
had more control of the fight overall
but it's not like Jake Paul is like he's
no Buster how does he feel though barely
beating a YouTuber
if you're a boxer and you're barely but
I think I think you can make the
argument that even though like Tommy
Fury is a boxer I think boxers in the
game couldn't really look at Tommy Fury
as a boxer he's a love Island guy you
know what I mean why is that well cause
like yeah he's part of the prestigious
Fury family but his brother is like one
of the goats of the heavyweights of
course he's he's the goat right now but
as far as he's probably seen more as a
reality star and a personality and if
he's had boxing fights but a lot of
people say like dude you haven't fought
anybody but it's also part of the
culture of boxing where when you're
coming up they kind of want you to fight
lower level Fighters right that's just
the culture of it anyway so there's a
lot of criticism there he's definitely a
boxer but I think in a lot of people's
eyes he's like he's not a real body he's
not the boxer yeah and I think for him
Jake Paul is legit he's putting his work
man yeah bro he's legit you can't you
can't deny this like how much more can
he really do relative to that
conversation and and I'm asking as a
non-fighter so I really wanted to ask as
well as me we're just fancier I'm a
professional boxer tell me ask me
anything like for example um when you're
talking about like patent uh like where
where is like Brandon Lee right now
because I feel like you know we we see
him he's been on the show he's like
super undefeated and and I feel like the
the kind of common conversation when
we're always talking about his fights
and stuff obviously he's dope he's
dominating but it's always like he's
fighting somebody that's lesser skilled
not always he drunk got dropped in his
last fight yeah but I think that's just
part of the nature of fighting right
it's like no matter what like is there
is it when you talk about padding fights
is there like a moment where it's like
okay time to like when is that moment I
don't think so from what I understand of
the boxing world there's a couple of
routes that people take and I think this
is kind of like the um like the magic of
boxing if you will where there's a lot
of different routes that you can go
so like UFC has like a way more and I
think the reason why UFC has grown so
big it has a very like scalable and
forecastable trajectory you get into MMA
Jam you do whatever and then you like
you have these agencies they'll put you
on boxing right now it's like half
fighting and half entertainment so it
depends on the route that you want to go
so if you go the entertainment route you
have Jake Paul you have all the like The
Gamers all the streamers and whatever
and those guys are making more money
than a lot of these like legit Fighters
I think Brandon comes from the pedigree
of actual fighting so previous to even
his like 20 something and oh record he's
already had like 200 fights since he was
like [__] 10 or something so he's a
tradition like he would be in the same
route as the guys that won Golden Gloves
Olympics like he's in the traditional
traditional boxing realm so I don't
think any of his fights have been padded
the other ones though literally like
let's say if you have a fight in Mexico
they'll go like hey cab driver I'll pay
you 300 bucks you're down to just you
weigh their weight the same way and
they'll do that so some of those guys
can camp drivers yeah literally you look
them up and they're like what the [__]
I've never even seen this guy this guy
has a o and O record and they'll and
they'll put four or five of those guys
in front of you to go hit my fighter
right here is 10-0 but the 10 Cal Drive
that's the culture in boxing that's the
culture in MMA as well like everyone cab
drivers fight MMA very well let me tell
you bro we got some wild stories well we
like when you first go from amateur to
Pro a lot of the times it's like you go
to these like really low level
like promotions where you're fighting at
a restaurant or like with a Elks Club an
Acapulco a Ukrainian Cultural Center
probably I've seen [__] like that or
Indian reservations right so for
instance like one of our first uh guys
who made the jump from this is an MMA he
fought from uh he was going from amateur
to Pro his first fight Pro we fought in
Soboba Casino
and it wasn't because you know at all it
was like the it was like the saboba and
the suburb was like a Indian reservation
and like past Riverside like past Hemet
it's not a cool drink no I wish I wish
it's a Soviet Union
yeah
but it's like it's especially when
you're first coming into the scene and
this is just like kind of standard
practice it's like you you fight someone
who's a kind of a low level Pro or it's
just your first jump and a lot of the
times you just never know what's gonna
happen so for instance for this guy
he was gonna fight Pro the fighter
pulled out like the date like the day of
the fight mostly I couldn't find anybody
right and we're at an Indian casino
we're warming up in like a recreational
center in the bathroom like that's where
we're warming up this guy's taking a
[__] and I'm holding pads for somebody
it's ridiculous you know that guy's
pissed too can you stop I'm trying to
concentrate yeah it's crazy like it
smells like [__] and then we're taping
his hands get in the zone you know put
the Vaseline on his eyes
but it smells like [__] and then and
then like like literally 20 minutes
before the fight and because the reason
why they fight on the Indian reservation
is because we don't necessarily meet
yeah there's no rules it's we don't need
an athletic commission to make sure
everything is like good to go athletic
commission by the state it's a state-run
government thing they come by they make
sure they have the doctors they have the
judges they have the referees everyone
is trained to make sure that this is
okay and legal to go on an inner
reservation you don't need anything
it's a dude with latex gloves just
standing there like the fight start the
fight starts a guy from Rite Aid comes
in with like I mean one of the refs
comes in with a Rite Aid bag just filled
with Vaseline like gloves just like
random [__] that's like okay this is
crazy uh anyway so you could put a roll
of quarters in your glove you kind of
could nobody would know nobody would
really know anyway so the guy pulls out
20 minutes before the fight so we're
like we need an opponent he's gonna
fight in like an hour or so so we're
asking around they're going to the crowd
hey you guys want to fight for like 200
bucks hey you want to fight for 200
bucks you know what's here yes they go
to a cornerman
a quarterman is pretty much my role in
this in this situation where he's a he's
going to coach one of his buddies who's
going to fight they go hey man you want
to fight he's like hell yeah I'm down
this guy fights in cargo shorts which
isn't if this is athletic State
commission this is not legal
this [__] comes out and he's a
fighter himself but he wasn't training
for for a fight he just was like yeah
yeah I'm down so
we fight this guy my buddy fights this
guy he beats him up but it's like such a
wild [__] thing because 20 minutes
ago he was like I'm not was that guy
Eddie good I'm sure he was I'm sure he
was pretty good but like he's not like
he just wasn't at that level like I'm
sure he was good but just not on that
night I just imagined it the cook coming
out like I'll [__] do it the waiter
is like all right killed my apron
every time we go to this promotion it's
like the wildest [__] we see one time we
were walking out and there's a stable of
Fighters that fight for this promotion
that live in Soboba that area and they
just get hired to fight Pros when fights
fall out like this they just need to
step in yeah and they're not really
Fighters they're not really like they're
fighting they're like substitute
teachers like yeah dude are they Native
Americans no I don't think so no we
didn't really see anybody maybe some of
them had native blood but I don't know I
don't think that's the part of I think
fight the fight game that people don't
understand at the end of the day it's an
entertain payment event so The Show Must
Go On so having people actually fill the
shoes is actually more important than
having a legitimate fight but that's
also why I think Brandon like people
would be like oh how come he doesn't
jump on these like uh big card fights I
don't think he wants to I think he's
trying to build his legacy so all his
fights if you see they're under Showtime
yeah yeah I have seen yeah they're like
one of the most legit like boxing like
they're probably the biggest boxing
promotion right now yeah so for him I
think he's like I don't traditional
Legacy Fighting yeah I don't want to be
that I want to like work my way up in
this realm and then maybe later on have
it pay off in a certain way whereas like
Jake Paul and stuff I think they're just
trying to do the fast track so they're
like doubling down on the more
entertainment aspect and I think for him
too he's fighting legit boxers but it's
getting to a point now where it's like
okay he's probably looking for the next
big fighter that's equal to where
they're at in their career that also has
a name so then they can find each other
and build each other's name up as they
go on like I'm sure Brandon Lee's gonna
fight some big names soon like it's just
a matter of
just getting two people to agree to
fight that's the hardest part because
everyone's got something to lose now you
know so Brandon Lee might be looking for
big names but these guys don't want to
find Brandon Lee because it's a big risk
so they'd rather fight maybe somebody
else so it's like there's a lot of
politics in there too so it is that just
basically like your manager that like
does all those negotiations it's your
manager it's the promotion an unboxing
but it's not necessarily like there's
like a records book that like it's like
oh now it's time you know yeah no it's
not really anything could happen that's
why I think the UFC although they get a
lot of hate they're one of the most
organized in terms of matchmaking that's
that's not the part of it that that it's
called like one of my friends Steffy she
just had a fight in Montebello or
something oh yeah I saw that yeah she
was supposed to and that person just
dropped out didn't want to fight pretty
much show up yeah because it happens a
lot really they just fail yeah it
happens a lot what's wrong with this
generation not coming to their job
interviews yeah
yeah I don't know dude it happens a lot
you're not out of touch I am when you
first brought up Brandon Lee like what
you know what about Brandon Lee and my
mom going dude he died bro
hahaha
[Music]